someone's finally gonna get that 401k
started Oh 401k basically it's a
retirement plan so you can never mind I
totally thought it was a lazy basically
about three dudes we live together we
work together we're fresh out of college
we do telemarketing we know today's
Thursday but we're gonna party like it's
Friday dude
it's Wednesday we're kinda just
ourselves on on the show we just way we
fight immersion ourselves on the show in
our show we take from our real lives get
it off our chest let the world know we
get dude fans yeah yeah yeah but we love
it's just good we've always had the
motto bring on the hint yeah that's been
a life model that we have bring on the
dudes and if the girls follow so be it
what are we spoking a world man you know
we're gonna do what we gonna do come on
girls we're working on the second season
right now and
there are some pretty cool guest stars
and we get into a little Arrested
Development this hint we're ruining this
this is supposed to be her lunch and she
said yeah I'll do that we are one one
last interview real quick were these
guys I don't know who they are sit down
fair coat in the middle Amy Winehouse
you know who what did you say earlier I
did say this they tried to take you to
rehab she should have said yes yes all
right tomorrow I need a cord and I just
need to go right in there see trill I
can almost set a spot of a chain here
publicist just come for our news what
are you doing that was a bullet point
for us she was like talking about heroin
yeah get out quick hit him up top with
the heroin and then leave bear coat in
the middle